ALONG RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
RYAN NOBLES UP ON CAPITOL HILL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> LET'S GET MORE ON ALL OF
THIS.
JOINING US NOW, THE FORMER
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF NEW
JERSEY, CHRIS CHRISTIE.
HIS NEW BOOK IS ENTITLED
"REPUBLICAN RESCUE: SAVING THE
PARTY FROM TRUTH DENIERS,
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS AND THE
DANGEROUS POLICIES OF JOE
BIDEN."
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO, MEADOWS, THE
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF SUGGESTED FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP SHOULD BECOME HOUSE
SPEAKER.
NOW HE'S ACTUALLY HANDING OVER
DOCUMENTS, ABOUT TO SIT DOWN FOR
A FORMAL INTERVIEW WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU THAT SO
MANY REPUBLICANS WANT IT BOTH
WAYS RIGHT NOW TRYING TO STAY ON
TRUMP'S GOOD SIDE WITHOUT FACING
THE CONSEQUENCES OF POTENTIALLY
SUBVERTING DEMOCRACY?
>> WOLF, I THINK THE KEY THING
HERE, AND I LOOK AT THIS AS A
FORMER UNITED STATES ATTORNEY,
IS WHAT IS THE NATURE OF THE
COOPERATION GOING TO BE?
I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN A
QUESTION, A REAL LEGAL QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE APPLIES HERE.
BUT UNTIL YOU KNOW WHAT
DOCUMENTS HE'S TURNED OVER AND
WHAT DOCUMENTS HE HASN'T TURNED
OVER, AND WHAT QUESTIONS HE'S
WILLING TO ANSWER OR NOT ANSWER,
WE'RE REALLY NOT GOING TO KNOW
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF TODAY'S
DEVELOPMENTS UP ON CAPITOL HILL.
BUT, OBVIOUSLY, THESE THINGS ARE
BEING LITIGATED IN COURT AS
WELL.
SO THIS IS GOING TO TAKE AWHILE.
AND I THINK THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO PRESS AND
THE FOLKS WHO CLAIM EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE A FUNDAMENTAL DECISION FROM
THEIR LAWYERS ABOUT WHETHER THEY
THINK IT REALLY APPLIES OR NOT.
I THINK IT'S A VERY TOUGH CALL.
>> YEAH, AND IN YOUR NEW BOOK
"REPUBLICAN RESCUE," YOU SAY THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP FOR THAT MATTER, NEED TO
MOVE ON FROM THE 2020 ELECTION
CONSPIRACIES BUT YOU HAVEN'T
NECESSARILY RULED OUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF SUPPORTING TRUMP
IF HE RUNS AGAIN IN 2024.
ISN'T THAT THE PROBLEM THAT
ULTIMATELY YOU AND SOME OF THE
PARTY COULD ACTUALLY FALL BACK
IN LINE BEHIND HIM ONCE AGAIN?
>> WOLF, LOOK.
WHAT THE BOOK IS ALL ABOUT IS TO
SAY WE NEED TO BE MUCH MORE
FOCUSED AS A PARTY AND QUITE
FRANKLY AS A COUNTRY, ON THE
NEXT ELECTION RATHER THAN THE
LAST ELECTION.
I MAKE IT REALLY CLEAR IN THE
BOOK THAT I BELIEVE THE LAST
ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN.
AND THAT TO CONTINUE TO SAY THAT
IS WRONG.
BUT WHAT WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED
ON IS THE NEXT ELECTION AND HOW
ARE REPUBLICANING GOING TO, IN
2022, FOCUS THE COUNTRY ON
RISING INFLATION, CRIME IN THE
STREETS, THE COVID CRISIS STILL
NOT UNDER CONTROL, AS YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER IN THE
PROGRAM.
AND IF WE WASTE TIME ON TALKING
ABOUT THE LAST ELECTION, WE WILL
NOT WIN THE NEXT ELECTION.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO BE
WORRIED ABOUT FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO
2024 BECAUSE THAT'S JUST AN
ENDLESS AMOUNT OF SPECULATION.
I'M FOCUSED ON 2022 AND TRYING
TO GET MY PARTY BACK TO BEING
THE PARTY THAT'S ABOUT THE
TRUTH, AND TALKS ABOUT THE
ISSUES AROUND THE KITCHEN TABLE
THAT FOLKS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
>> WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO THOSE
REPUBLICANS, THOUGH, LIKE
CONGRESSMAN RONNIE JACKSON,
PUSHING ALL THESE COVID
CONSPIRACY THEORIES OUT THERE.
>> LOOK, I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, HAS NOT
BEEN CONSISTENT IN WHAT THEY ARE
PUTTING OUT THERE REGARDING
COVID.
AND THAT CAUSED THE SPACE TO BE
CREATED FOR A LOT OF THIS STUFF
TO BE INSERTED.
HERE TO ME IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
THE SMARTEST THING FOR ANYBODY
OUT THERE IS TO GET VACCINATED.
IF YOU'VE GOTTEN VACCINATED AND
YOU'RE ELIGIBLE FOR A BOOSTER TO
GET A BOOSTER.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT HELPS
TO PUT YOU IN THE BEST POSITION
NOT TO GET SERIOUSLY ILL OR FACE
DEATH FROM COVID-19 AND ANY OF
THE VARIANTS.
AND I THINK THAT SHOULD BE THE
STRONG AND CONSISTENT MESSAGE
AND WE SHOULD BE EDUCATING THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT YET BEEN
VACCINATED AS TO WHY ON THE
FACTS AND THE MERITS IT MAKES
SINCE FOR THEM TO DO IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
INDOCTRINATED.
THEY WANT TO BE EDUCATED.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION AS A
GOVERNMENT TO DO THAT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
FALLEN DOWN ON THAT REGARD AND
IT CREATES SPACE FOR ALL KINDS
OF THINGS THAT MAKE NO SENSE.
WHAT MAKES SENSE IS STAND UP,
GET VACCINATED, GET BOOSTED IF
YOU'RE ELIGIBLE, BECAUSE THAT'S
GOING TO KEEP YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY THE SAFEST THEY CAN BE.
>> YOU SPEAK WITH SOME PERSONAL
HISTORY.
YOU WERE VERY, VERY SICK WITH
COVID.
YOU WRITE ABOUT IT RATHER
FRANKLY IN YOUR BOOK AS WELL.
LET ME ASK YOU, GOVERNOR, ABOUT
THESE NEWLY UNEARTHED COMMENTS
FROM LAUREN BOEBERT CALLING THE
FIRST TWO MUSLIM WOMEN, MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS, QUOTE, BLACKHEARTED
AND EVIL.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT YOUR
PARTY THAT BOEBERT APPARENTLY
THINKS ALL THIS IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO HELP HER POLITICALLY AS
SHE LAUNCHES THESE CLEARLY
RACIST ATTACKS.
>> WOLF, HERE'S WHAT I'M
STARTLED BY IS THAT WE'RE
SPENDING TIME TALKING ABOUT THIS
BUT WE DON'T SPEND NEARLY ENOUGH
TIME, IF ANY TIME, ON THE
CLEARLY ANTI-SEMITIC STATEMENTS
THAT CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR HAS
MADE.
NOW LOOK, I DON'T THINK ANY
LANGUAGE THAT IS USED THAT TAKES
AFTER PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR
RELIGION IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO BUT I'M STARTLED AND FED UP
WITH THE IDEA THAT WE'RE NOT
SPENDING TIME TALKING ABOUT WHAT
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR HAS CLEARLY
ENGAGED IN ON THE FLOOR OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AND AT
OTHER EVENTS.
CLEARLY STATEMENTS THAT ARE
ANTI-SEMITIC, ANTI-ISRAEL AND
YET WE'RE SPENDING TIME ON THIS.
I'M WILLING TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
THAT'S FULL AND ROBUST REGARDING
OTHERS' COMMENTS ABOUT OTHERS'
RELIGIONS BUT I'M NOT JUST GOING
TO PICK ON ONE SIDOR THE OTHER.
THE FACT IS THAT CONGRESSWOMAN
OMAR'S COMMENTS OVER THE COURSE
OF TIME THAT ARE ANTI-SEMITIC,
AGAINST JEWS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
ABSOLUTELY UNCALLED FOR.
>> I CAN TELL YOU, WE'VE COVERED
ALL OF THOSE COMMENTS AND THESE
GO WAY BACK THAT ILHAN OMAR HAS
MADE.
SHE'S APOLOGIZED FOR SEVERAL OF
THOSE.
WE HAVE NOT IGNORED THOSE
COMMENTS.
WE'VE REPORTED IT.
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW YOU
HAVE THIS REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, GOVERNOR, ACTUALLY
SUGGESTING THAT THIS MEMBER OF
CONGRESS MIGHT BE A SUICIDE
BOMBER AND MIGHT -- AND SHE'S
JOKING ABOUT THAT AS IF THAT'S A
FUN JOKE.
>> LOOK, I DON'T -- I HAVEN'T
HEARD CONGRESSWOMAN BOEBERT'S
COMMENTS SO I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
EVALUATE THEM AND WHETHER IT WAS
JUST ILL-TIMED JOKE OR SOMETHING
WORSE.
BUT I HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR OVER
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME, WOLF, AND
I'M VERY DISTURBED BY IT.
AS THE FORMER GOVERNOR OF A
STATE THAT HAS A VERY LARGE
JEWISH POPULATION IN OUR STATE.
I UNDERSTAND AND SAW ON A
REGULAR BASIS WHAT ACTS OF
ANTI-SEMITISM AND LANGUAGE
REGARDING ANTI-SEMITISM HAS
DONE.
BUT ALSO, AS U.S. ATTORNEY, IN
NEW JERSEY IN THE AFTERMETATH O
9/11, I ALSO STOOD UP FOR THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY AND TOOK A LOT
OF ABUSE FOR NOMINATING A MUSLIM
AMERICAN TO THE STATE COURT IN
NEW JERSEY.
AND I STOOD UP THEN AND SAID I'M
NOT GOING TO MAKE EVALUATIONS
BASED UPON PEOPLE'S RELIGION.
SO MY RECORD IS REALLY CLEAR ON
THIS AND I TAKE YOUR WORD FOR IT
THAT YOU'VE COVERED
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR'S COMMENTS.
BUT I HAVEN'T SEEN ENOUGH OF IT
IN TERMS OF THE COVERAGE ACROSS
THE MEDIA AND HAVING THAT
SENSITIVITY AS A FORMER GOVERNOR
OF NEW JERSEY ON BOTH SIDES, THE
JEWISH SIDE AND MUSLIM SIDE.
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR THAT KIND
OF LANGUAGE AND I THINK
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR HAS TO BE
HELD TO ACCOUNT JUST AS MUCH AS
ANYBODY ELSE.
>> AS I SAID, OVER THE PAST YEAR
OR TWO OR THREE WE'VE COVERED A
LOT OF THOSE COMMENTS SHE MADE.
LET ME PLAY FOR YOU WHAT
CONGRESSWOMAN BOEBERT, YOU SAID
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT SHE'S SAID.
I'LL PLAY THIS LITTLE CLIP WE
HAD FROM SEPTEMBER.
WATCH THIS.
>> ONE OF MY STAFFERS ON HIS
FIRST DAY WITH ME GOT INTO AN
ELEVATOR IN THE CAPITOL.
AND IN THAT ELEVATOR, WE WERE
JOINED BY ILHAN OMAR.
WELL, IT WAS JUST US THREE IN
THERE.
AND I LOOKED OVER AND I SAID,
WELL, LOOKY THERE, IT'S THE
JIHAD SQUAD.
>> YOU WANT TO REACT TO THAT?
>> LOOK, THIS IS THE SAME KIND
OF THING THAT, YOU KNOW, WHEN MY
MUSLIM AMERICAN NOMINEE FOR THE
STATE COURT IN NEW JERSEY WAS
BROUGHT BEFORE THE SENATE
COMMITTEE IN NEW JERSEY, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT ONE OF THE
SENATORS ASKED HIM RIGHT OFF THE
BAT WAS, CAN YOU EXPLAIN JIHAD
TO ME.
I THINK THAT ANY GENERALIZATIONS
THAT WE MAKE ABOUT ANYONE,
WHETHER IT'S THAT OR WHETHER
IT'S THE THINGS THAT
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR HAS SAID
REGARDING JEWISH AMERICANS IN
THIS COUNTRY, DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING TO BRING THE COUNTRY
TOGETHER.
NOW TAIT APPEARS TO ME FROM
WATCHING THE VIDEO THAT SHE WAS
MAKING A JOKE THERE BUT IN THE
END, SOMETIMES JOKES ARE NOT IN
THE BEST TASTE AND ARE NOT WITH
THE BEST IDEA BEHIND THEM.
BUT IN THE END, WHAT BOTHERS ME
MORE, WOLF, AND I WANT TO REPEAT
THIS IS THAT CONGRESSWOMAN
OMAR'S COMMENTS HAVE NOT BEEN
JOKES.
AND COULDN'T BE INTERPRETED AS
THEY HAVE BEEN SERIOUS POLICY
STATEMENTS THAT SHE HAS MADE
THAT FOCUS ON ANTI-SEMITISM AND
OUR ANTI-JEWISH COMMENTS THAT WE
CAN'T STAND FOR.
EVERYONE CAN INTERPRET IT
HOWEVER THEY WANT.
I THINK ANY OF THOSE JOKES ARE
ILL ADVISED.
BUT IN THE END, THAT WAS CLEARLY
SOMEONE TRYING TO BE FUNNY THAT
YOU CAN SAY WAS OR WASN'T FUNNY.
BUT CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR IS
TALKING ABOUT SERIOUS POLICY
ISSUES THAT ARE ANTI-SEMITIC,
WOLF, AND I THINK THAT'S OF A
MUCH GRAVER CONCERN.
>> HERE'S THE DIFFERENCE,
GOVERNOR.
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR, THOSE
COMMENTS THAT WERE INTERPRETED
AS BEING ANTI-SEMITIC, SHE
APOLOGIZED.
WE DIDN'T HEAR LAUREN BOEBERT
APOLOGIZE.
>> LOOK, WHEN YOU MAKE
ANTI-SEMITIC COMMENTS, AND I
KNOW YOU'RE SENSITIVE TO THIS AS
ANYBODY, GETTING CAUGHT AND THEN
APOLOGIZING, TO ME, IS OKAY, IF,
IN FACT, THEN YOUR POLICY
POSITIONS DON'T ALSO APPEAR TO
BE ANTI-SEMITIC.
AND MY CONCERN ABOUT
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR, AS I'VE SAID
A NUMBER OF TIMES TO YOU NOW IS
THAT IT'S NOT JUST THE WORDS.
IT'S THE ACTIONS.
AND I AM CONCERNED THAT AN
APOLOGY IS MADE BECAUSE YOUR
HAND GOT CAUGHT IN THE COOKIE
JAR BUT YOU CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
POLICIES, AND WE SAW THIS IN THE
VOTE REGARDING THE MISSILE
DEFENSE SYSTEM IN ISRAEL AND THE
IRON DOME.
WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF POLICY
THINGS THAT SEEM